ok
[Applaus]
und damit herzlich willkommen hier heute
meine damen und herren seiner neuen
folge oracle mit luca luka hallo wie
geht's dir
a
hallo hallo hast du eine kamera
oracle geht sich darum dass man die
kamera nach 2000 jahre später hast du
ein vogel sind deco so renate naber
ok dann leise und langweilig nacken holt
ja sofort dass ich mein andere kinder
holen sich irgendwie hunde oder katzen
oder kaninchen und du hast mäuse und
ratten und hat mich auch ein hund hast
du auch christ ein hund denn die ratten
nein
okay das ein braver hund haben deine
raten deinen namen
ok zusammen erkennst du eigentlich
fortnight spielst du fordern halten ehe
ich kann warum du kannst nicht sah da
sind wir schon 29 habe ich auch komplett
ok krass respekt so sollte es sein
freunde
ja
die frage geht ob ich gerade aufnehme
also falls sie jemanden grüßen möchtest
kannst es jetzt gerne tun begrüßten die
laser luca auf instagram du spielst du
eigentlich vor neid
ich möchte dass fans von mir fordert
henze machen aber bisher spielt keiner
fort nightly hinzu meine brille
nein denn mit der gehe ich mal raus in
den schatten
na wie geht's
ja ja blendend nun ein zimmer sind sehen
wie 4000 grad gerade bitte ob ich hier
bin ich bin froh wie das wii ja was hast
du gesagt die natürlich sagen dass man
das spiel sofort und kraß kannst du
einen ford tanz machen
o verbindung ist wie abgestürzt
cool cool dass man ne ich mag meine fans
[Musik]
mit luca nennen als gut
luca heissig
hi
u
ok spielt fortnight könnt ihr einen
vorteil tanz das thema dieses video soll
sein dass fans von mir fordert es machen
aber bisher kann keine ein tanz waren
ich heiße luca war danke 110 euro du ich
habe eine ganz kurze frage an dich und
zwar suche ich leute die ford leid henze
machen können
leonskaja ich habe jetzt so viele leute
dass er geredet und keiner kann einen
perfekten vorteil tanzbaren ich kenne
die meinen fotos zeigen wow
[Gelächter]
hallo
hallo wie geht's denn madame wie heißt
du denn jetlag geschrieben dass die
sydney heißt wohnt in australien nicht
deutschland euch mal ein instrument für
die spielen hier live vor der kamera
warum machst du das war voll gut
eigentlich soll ich doch mal wirklich
ich heute schon bald so gut weil hier
soll ich noch mal spielen für dich
vielleicht kann hier ein privatkonzert
für sydney in deutschland alter hast du
ne fette stier hinpasst und ja ich hör
dich
kennst du kennst du kennst du bibi und
tina ja da heißt einfährt sabrina bis
das du du sabrina ich habe eine ganz
kurze frage an dich erkennst du
fortnight das habe ich gerade gespielt
und dann hast du gezielt hat und günstig
auflagen ok kannst du erkennst du four
tänze aber einen tanz noch nicht fest
die einen vorteil haben vor der kamera
verborgen an der stelle wird das heutige
wird jetzt allerdings auch band meine
damen und herren ich hatte mal wieder
richtig bock auf oracle wenn euch die
serie gefällt also dass ich mit euch
quasi auf oracle video chatten dann lass
mir leid da sind
da wird eine neue folge oracle kommen
meine damen und herren wir macht dieses
format ultra ultra krass viel spaß und
deswegen würde ich an der stelle einfach
mal das video beenden
[Musik]